think about a defining moment in your
life a moment that had a major impact on
who you are today a moment that made you
rethink your priorities I wonder how
many of you are thinking about a moment
of adversity
maybe you involved in an accident we
left a broken relationship or you fail
it's something that was really important
to you when such moment that made me
rethink what matters most to me was also
caused by adversity it was December 2004
days before Christmas I was 13 years old
and had bruises all over my body though
at least 50 of them and when it started
as a normal nosebleed here and there
turned to something abnormal and
concerning so went to my local doctor
who took a blood sample in that same
night I was admitted to the hospital a
number of tests followed until the
doctors could tell my parents and me the
diagnosis leukemia and I can still very
vividly remember my first reaction
hearing this well at least it's not
cancer
well my parents had to tell me that
leukemia in fact was cancer and I was
devastated would follow up with long
months of chemotherapy every morning I
got an infusion of something that looked
and smelled and indeed was toxic I lost
all my energy most of my hair and some
mornings that couldn't quite recognize
that face I saw in the mirror and in
turn out that chemotherapy alone
wouldn't do the job I needed a stem-cell
transplant from a genetic twin no one in
my family was so matched so the doctors
turned to the worldwide registries of
stem cell donors and luckily they found
a genetic twin stem cell transplant
saved my life but this is not the end of
the story
it's the beginning this is not a talk
about cancer and to talk about life
having survived cancer my attitude to
its life completely changed I realized
that my life is finite and it's my own
choice and responsibility to make it
matter going back to school was a blast
I enjoyed studying which is probably not
the most common thing for a 15 year old
started writing for local newspaper
joined a drama group and found my
passion for acting I created an exhibit
that art cancer to educate the public
together a fellow patient traveled all
across Europe and couldn't care less
what other people thought about me
overcoming cancer was the catalyst that
kept me pushing forward in life and
taught me license some people only learn
when their life is coming to an end but
now more than a decade after surviving
cancer the clarity of this defining
experience started to wear off
well my attitude towards life is still
very much shaped by that perspective
that I gained lessons that I learned
less present in everyday life and my
auto pilot started taking over again so
in the past few years have spent far too
much time with people only took energy
but never gave me energy I worry too
much about what other people think about
me and work too many hours and treated
my
with virtual respect think about your
own moments of adversity how much of the
choices you make still shaped by that
experience since coming to Stanford a
lot of time to reflect on my own life
and I realized something lasting change
in life doesn't come through the
occasional setback or crises lasting
change in life happens in the small
moments of each day the small moments
that give us the opportunity to reflect
on our lives and reconfirm of change we
want to become so the other day a close
friend was asking me what's one thing in
your life that you want to change and
what keeps you from doing it I instantly
knew the answer being single
it's sure to be relationships matter a
lot to mean in that moment I feel
inspired to finally do something about
it but seconds later the voices in my
head started shouting this is a bad plan
online dating is time consuming and
random and there's a lot of creepy
people on there meeting new people it
can lead to rejection and isn't you know
complicated relationship just more work
than being alone this is exactly the
pattern that keeps repeating over and
over again in the moments that can
potentially be defining for us you
realize that you want to change
something but then you stop you realize
that you want to finally end that
unhealthy relationship quit that job you
hate spend more time with that friend
stop volunteering eat healthier start
working out say I love you to someone
whatever it is but you don't take action
you realize that you find this talk or
conversation of bukata or article
inspiring but then that moment passes
too often we let that moment slip
through our fingers
because who don't feel empowered to make
it a choice we don't feel empowered to
overcome the obstacles but in these
moments we have to go further we refract
on what's holding us back and make a
choice to act so that conversation with
my friend kept me thinking yes I can
find a thousand and I'm creative so
probably even more reasons why dating is
time-consuming and complicated
hey it's important to me so it's worth
the effort the only way I can lose it's
been up doing anything at all and
looking at my own life I can thank many
of these small moments were reflecting
and what's holding me back and making a
choice to act can actually bring me a
little bit closer to who I want to be so
last year for example I spent a lot of
time recruiting for an internship and
consulting although deep down I knew
that that's not quite the thing I want
to do with my life but it seemed
prestigious and other people excited so
I gave it a shot and went to all these
recruiting events and case prep sessions
and interviews and well actually ended
up with an awful ladder and holding that
thing in my hand
I thought well it's like a solo plan we
stupid to turn that down and I was this
close to signing until I stumbled upon
my Stanford application essay on what
matters most to me and why and rereading
that I realized what should have known
before that spending time of consulting
wouldn't bring me any closer to that
Korean media that I want to have so took
action turned it down at the end of last
year I felt pretty exhausted I over
committed to too many classes and
outside projects and activities and
social commitments and all that stuff we
all will commit to many of you do and I
felt that my mind lost his usual clarity
in focus and sitting in the airport
waiting for my flight back home for
winter break felt like I have to do
something about this but the only idea I
had was meditation because I remembered
conversations with friends who talked
about the benefits of meditate
meditation but I didn't quite like the
idea of sitting cross-legged and
focusing my breath like 10 minutes and
hoping all be better but truth be told I
didn't have any better idea so I
downloaded that meditation app that
friend recommended and tried it out and
what can I say I'm doing it every day
now and my mind is a lot clearer I'm
actually taking
meditation class next quarter and this
list of small defining moments we're
reflecting and acting can make a
difference is practically endless and
I'm not a master and acting on all these
moments yet I'm still figuring things
out but I want you to think about your
own life think about yesterday what did
you do who did you talk to when did you
feel inspired
what were the moments where you thought
I should do this or I should stop doing
that but you didn't take action you left
that conversation you put that book
aside you closed your eyes we think too
much
and hold back too much we want to do so
many things in our lives but we don't
even start because we think we can wait
don't wait for cancer don't wait for
adversity to hit you in the face but the
next time you think I should do this
don't go back to your busy life don't go
back to autopilot but instat ask
yourself what's holding you back
reflect and act right now your defining
moment can be right now thank you